est ce que tu sais ce que ça fait de
réaliser ses rêves les eaux je t'ai vu
travailler au bal d un bon bah mais un
barman ça casse pas la gueule conclure
je te mérite pas reliés aux tu peux pas
savoir quand je t'aime et tu sais pas
qui suit
je veux savoir quel deal il a passé avec
ce psychopathe de barman raid sûr que
vous avez besoin nous ce genre de truc
ça entache la réputation papa doit y
aller à barcelone
de me rater ce creux
vva
tu t'es perdu mon pote arrête de faire
chier et casse toi
toi t'es pas bavard ça sentait pas bon
pour essayer de garder ton sens de
l'humour bonjour
tu vas me causer des des problèmes mon
garçon où tu vas être un bon ami chez
rester calme
[Musique]
d autres
il faut que je te dise quelque chose
mais ça va être tout de suite que
maintenant c'est plus un secret
tu serais prêt à faire n'importe quoi
pour
tu devrais être désolé
[Musique]
on ne pourra plus jamais parler